[Music]
the king enigma
okay d4
oh right well
let's let's go with d5 which is mainly
what we've been focusing on in the speed
run and i want to play the queen's game
of decline because i want to steer the
game into
positional waters hopefully i'll be able
to demonstrate what you know winning
positionally at this level requires so
we're going to revert back to what we
started the speedrun with
not the most interesting opening but um
obviously this is the gold standard for
solid responses to 1d4
and it's existed forever and nobody's
even come close to refuting it okay cd
so
this leads to us and knight takes c5 is
is a variation of the semi terrace which
we're not going to play it's a totally
different structure does anybody know
what this structure is called there's a
name for this variation and more broadly
this uh somewhat imbalanced structure
it's called the carlsbad it's as far as
i know named after a city in germany
where this structure was reached in a
bunch of tournaments in in the early
1900s
and
you know i think probably books have
been written on the carlsbad i could
talk for hours and hours about the ideas
um of this structure
so anything i do in this game will be a
pitiful pitifully inadequate explanation
but what i'm going to do is kind of
relatively quickly make a bunch of
standard carl's bad moves and then after
the game i'm going to give you a little
bit of context so the first thing we
want to do is go c6 which i think most
of you can understand we want to
reinforce the d5 pawn
and the carl's about this dark squid
bishop sometimes goes to d6 but
generally goes to e7
okay it stops the pin
and uh this is generally going to be the
square
now we can throw in h6 at any moment but
it's not
obligatory so we're just going to
continue developing with castles
and then of course bishop d3 so
now we want to be a little bit careful
white is threatening bishop takes f6
so we start with knight bd7 reinforcing
the other knight and then as in the roy
lopez and as in many many other defenses
and and openings where is this knight
ultimately going to go
where is this knight ultimately going to
go
one of two squares
yeah so either g6 or e6 and in order to
accomplish both we need to slide the
rook over to e8 and then play knight f8
notice that from f8 it also defends the
pawn on h7 so we're not allowing bishop
takes f6 and bishop takes h7 rook a1
white nose so so this this guy knows uh
all of the all of the main moves
now the setup that i like the most is
actually putting the knight on e6
but in order to do that we need to throw
an h6 because if we don't 96 there's
again bishop takes f6 and after the game
i'll show some of the alternative setups
here so 96 we get the knight into the
center yeah we blocked the bishop a
little bit but we can also fianchetto it
okay f3 so white is preparing e4
which is again correct this is white's
main idea
now black has a couple of tools
uh that can be used to counteract that
idea the main one is to push c5 at the
right moment and create counter play on
the queen side you can also play b5 b4
and get counter play this way i'm not a
specialist by any means in the carlsbad
so
what i do here with black should be
taken with quite a grain of salt
we can go c5 immediately here
but i think it's important to point out
that e4 is not yet a threat as far as i
can tell because de4
will happen and then the pawn on d4 is
going to hang so i think we have time to
go b6 and prepare c5
or potentially even fiance the bishop
first and then play c5 bishop g3
so still e4 is not a threat because
still the d4 pawn hangs so
let's get our bishop out first and on
the next move we'll almost certainly go
c5
yeah we can harass the bishop but then
the bishop will drop back to f2 okay so
let's go c5 enough procrastinating
and it kind of self-explanatory why you
know this is a good move it creates
tension in the center and it distracts
white's attention away from
the center so bishop b5 now this bishop
is annoying so let's uh drop our knight
back to d7 and dislodge it or at least
try to dislodge it
rook d1 okay this is where
i think our opponent is starting to go
slightly off the rails that's a weird
move
i mean it allows knight takes bishop
which kind of ruins white structure now
i think i understand what what
our opponent is trying to go for which
is
potentially f4 f5 so not not a dumb idea
actually
so we we definitely have to be careful
about this um
now what we're going to do is the
following we're going to
get our queen to c7 escaping the x-ray
that x-ray was annoying
bishop
oh
no but knight d5 we have queen takes you
pub i don't think that's an issue
i don't think that's an issue
i honestly didn't see this now we have
bishop takes d5 and g6
but who can tell me what annoying idea
white has in that resulting position i
think a lot of people forget that this
is a thing
so bishop d5 rook d5 g6 it does trap the
bishop
but white can sacrifice the bishop
for
three pawns bishop takes g6 fg queen g6
our king is wide open
and uh
it gets quite annoying
okay
oh that's a good move
that is a very good move well we have to
drop our queen back probably to b8
i mean we don't have any other squares
i still think we're very solid here
bishop back to e4
well he's given us an opportunity to
preserve our bishop so let's preserve
our bishop bishop f8
knight g3
okay
now what we're going to do and again i
have to speed up a little bit because
he's playing very well and
i don't want to lose on time
we're gonna go b5 c4 and then try to get
a knight to c5
knight c3
okay
well we can play a6 to defend the pawn
but knight takes b5 is not a threat so
we can continue with our plan
thank you nifa
knight b5 we play bishop take c4 and
queen b5 rook d7
ooh forgot about that
um well bishop takes bishop knight takes
and then i guess rookie seven
this is not ideal
okay let me think so knight c5 rook f7
yeah he's certainly playing like a carl
i guess we have to go rookie seven here
i don't like king g8 because that that
keeps his rook on the seventh he takes
it that's weird
i don't think that's correct
f5
oh he wants to play f6
i think this guy is speed running
wait knight g5 is this actually good
no i mean obviously i'm this is
obviously sus i i i don't know
if i'm like truly i mean i i don't know
if i just playing well i can't tell
but i know
okay so it takes takes
is this so good for white takes like
whoa
h4
if this is best then
that's a telltale sign but wait a second
no but knight h7 i mean is this so good
oh he's one is he's also won his last 15
games um
okay let's go queen e8
i don't know
i don't get the sense that i'm playing
an engine
i mean i kind of do but
i don't get the sense that i'm getting
blown off the board
although i kind of am
now already the fact that this guy knew
all of the key carlsbad ideas is already
like extremely unusual for this level
but
not impossible what if he studied it so
as usual in these cases we'll
investigate the game
no need for any accusations at this
moment
there's no need to just say anything
right now we'll we'll look at the game
and i'll make the determination based on
evidence oh my god rook b2 there's rook
c8 king g7 knight f5 king g6 and g4 with
mate
no i i said it's us enough moving on
let's try to play the game as best i can
and then we'll look afterward what i'm
saying is
it's not not sus it is but there's no
need to keep repeating it
and i i would like us to focus on the
game instead
now
i'm not
i don't feel like white is playing this
ideally to be honest
i'm gonna offer a draw see what happens
declined okay
okay but wait now it takes
now knight f6 rook b2 i think and then
rogue b8 it goes work f7
no but this is not
perfect
i think we can go here
okay
i should be able to draw this
although the way that he's playing in
the time situation i i don't know
if he moves this rook it's going to be
super sus because then no it goes g3
okay
yeah obviously the four seconds of move
is like the extremely telltale sign
okay so we're gonna push our pawn this
knight is a very good defender actually
this knight is a great defender
ooh
taking his time
look at that
king f1 really riley
okay knight f5 threatening mate or
threatening to win my knight so i have
to go either king jade or knight f8
probably should go nf8
okay
keep pushing
okay wait let me think so now we can go
here again
back
ah king f2 is correct okay let's just
push this a2 i don't know if this is
good enough we're just going to
push this to a2
if he doesn't take i'll be sussed out
okay
okay let's go here
okay now the thing is this
the thing is this if white moves their
king to g2 then we go rookie one
if he moves his king to
e2 then we have rook h1 and then rook h2
check
i mean i can hold this i think
let me think
good chunk maybe
just hoping for a mouse slip at this
point
i mean it's obvious
now rook h1 there was night covering on
g2
and i'm i'm proud that i lasted as long
as i did honestly
and he's
there's definitely some moves that white
is playing which are not best
although maybe they are i don't know
dude no this is an amazing technique
rook a8 and
lmao
i mean you really shouldn't make it that
obvious if he's going to do this and
he's going to think on rook a7 exactly
the same amount of time this guy is not
an experienced shooter
i actually said dude don't make it so
obvious and he responded loser
look at him spending like the same
amount of time on rook takes g4
okay
gg
okay well
i don't love putting these on youtube
but let's analyze for the sake of
youtube ugh
ridiculous i mean people are just
absurd
my accuracy was not so bad
okay so this is the carlsbad
yeah and by the way for cheating review
i don't use the the thing that tells you
whether it's best or not i use this
interface because it tells you the top
three moves
okay so rook c1
c5 which should be five is correct
or like one of the top three moves
okay rook d1 is not correct um actually
it's the third move it was oh it's the
second move oh my god oh it's the first
move oh your cd1 okay this is already
like insane
um
yep correct f4 screw okay
yeah i mean
this guy did not try to not make it
obvious
knight c3 is
up there it's number it's number two
you can see it was number two briefly
rook d7 is top
this is top two
and top top
okay yeah now let me this is
nh4 is also the top move
yeah yeah no i mean it's so obvious
queen e4 i mean
there's even nothing there's simply
nothing i mean i i survived this pretty
well you know i got this into an end
game which i could have drawn
rooks yeah and literally every move this
guy cheated on
i think at maybe around this point
no but still i mean g3 is top
okay maybe king f1 oh king f1 is number
three
everything is top three moves
and i almost drew this game
f i should have gone f5 this is a this
was hasty
and knight e3 is correct this was hasty
knight c2 is top move
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i mean we're reporting him obviously
all right yeah it's
the time usage doesn't matter by the way
guys it's that's not the defining
feature
but yeah trust me that this guy will not
last more than a day
i actually played very well i mean
given who i was up against i found some
some good ideas
but yeah first loss a speedrun
i quickly understood you know if i'm
honest with you guys and i i presented
differently for youtube and stuff i
i'm suspicious
long before i say that i'm suspicious
because i don't like it's very important
to err on the side of caution here
and i think it's important to instill a
culture in chess of like not of
gathering evidence but
already here i was suspicious because
most people in the 1700s do not know
like all of the right ideas in the
carlsbad
um so that's incredibly uncommon
and then when rook cd1 happened i was
like okay
he's definitely cheating thank you lexie
anyways um
[Music]
you